Can i tell you a secret
i'm working with an avenger
can i speak to your manager
I didn't realize we were supposed to bring guns
it's almost christmas i can't
go home until i fix this
should we be worried i'll be
on for christmas i promise
sorry we're santa of regular
arrows oh my god trick arrows
we're saving the holidays
marvel studios hawkeye first two episodes
streaming november 24th only on disney plus
Welcome back everyone this will be my new marvel
hawkeye trailer video there's a whole bunch of
easter eggs and a couple new characters that they
feature in this including marvel's version of the
joker whose name is clown as you can probably
assume we also have some more marvel daredevil
easter eggs so i'll explain those too if you're
brand new to the channel i'll be doing videos for
all the episodes and remember they're dropping the
first two episodes on the first day but usually
episodes are weekly it's just they have a bit of a
log jam in terms of big marvel disney plus content
and they want to be able to drop that mandalorian
book of boba fett spin-off series before the end
of the year it just means you get more content
faster usually people are happy about that a
lot of you have noticed during the trailers that
hawkeye is wearing his hearing aids jeremy renner
did confirm that during the events of this series
hawkeye is slowly losing his hearing now he's not
deaf or anything like that but at this point in
the timeline after avengers end game he's slowly
been losing his hearing so they're just being more
accurate to that it's possible that he was losing
his hearing before this and they just decided
not to deal with that during avengers end game
eventually during the hawkeye story that they're
basing this on he also does kind of go deaf in one
ear after one of the villains stabs him in the
ear as you would probably go definite ear after
somebody stabbed you so i think what they're gonna
do during the series is they'll just use that as
a big plot point like there'll be some big fight
that he has or some situation that he has to get
out of where he won't have his hearing aids and
he'll just have to call an audible and learn to
fight better without his hearing there's a brand
new scene of hayley steinfeld's kate bishop in the
elevator of her building just bragging to the
old man about working with hawkeye i'm working
with an avenger gonna tell you a little bit
of a secret there like a really funny twist
on the hail hydra captain america whisper oh and
by the way i'm working with the avengers there
is a minor plot point during the matt fraction
comic book story that they're basing this on
involving an old man from their building this
could wind up being that guy something unfortunate
winds up happening to somebody in their building
they're the same scene of them in the ice rink
at rockefeller center fighting the tracksuit
mafia right before christmas in their full
comic book costumes they've been releasing promo
art of him in the purple costumes hawkeye has had
a bunch of different comic book costumes this is
just based on the one from the more modern comics
kate bishop's costume also meant to be her comic
book costume the bow that she's using is also
way more hardcore so i'm assuming that hawkeye
probably winds up giving her some of her gear
this is the same scene of them crashing the mafia
auction the scene of the black tie banquet in
midtown somewhere in a super swanky restaurant
with a bunch of mob members including kate
bishop's mother you see them get dressed up and
walk in like they're gonna infiltrate like kate
bishop is also wearing a black tie suit you don't
see him during any of this footage but they also
feature another deep cut hawkeye villain from
the classic comics called swordsman during this
and it seems like he's working with eleanor
bishop kate bishop's mother and that'll explain
her association with all these hitmen these
classic hawkeye villains and the marvel daredevil
characters from the netflix series because of
all those kingpin reports it's all about the
mob in new york city so of course kingpin would
be involved with that that also gets into what's
going on with the maya lopez echo character also
a classic daredevil character from the comics
i'll talk about her in a second too but like
they have a brand new version of that scene
where hawkeye lets himself get captured by the
tracksuit mafia like he's just kind of sitting
there like it's no big deal kate bishop comes
crashing through to save him all awkward i didn't
realize we were supposed to bring guns then this
scene of maya lopez's echo and the clown marvel's
joker character like i said earlier is happening
in a completely different part of the episode or
a different episode entirely i've already talked
a lot about the echo character so she's basically
a mercenary working for kingpin who killed
her father then raised her as his own daughter
turning her into this really badass assassin
then using her to go after all of his enemies
including mostly daredevil she is a deaf character
like i said hawkeye is going deaf during the
series so that's going to be a big plot point
but whereas hawkeye is slowly going deaf she's
been deaf for pretty much her whole life so she's
already acclimated to that style of fighting and
one of her big abilities is echoing other people's
moves thus the name echo it's a very task master
like ability where she's able to copy people's
moves on the fly the funny thing with the clown
character so obviously we have to talk about this
whole joker parody because he was created by matt
fraction during the run that they're basing
the series on i totally cannot pronounce what
his actual name is like the clown is just what
people call him inside the marvel universe but
clearly matt fraction created him as a parody of
the joker so he's not really meant to be the joker
he just looks a lot like the joker and he's a bit
crazy like the joker but he's someone who came to
america with his family as part of a circus like
he grew up in the circus thus the whole clown
moniker his family was killed his best friend
was killed and that sort of drove him to become
a mercenary later what happens is he winds up
working for kingpin and then the tracksuit mafia
winds up hiring him to kill hawkeye after hawkeye
just basically runs them all over town kicking
their asses which is basically what's happening
during the hawkeye series here in the episodes
this is actually very similar to the plot of the
batman dark knight movie where you have the mob
trying to fight batman being completely unable to
do so so they wind up hiring somebody even worse
the joker that's basically what happens with
the tracksuit mafia during the hawkeye series
it's gone he's not wearing his makeup here
but this is what he looks like with his full
makeup on so as you can see obviously he looks
like he's got clown makeup on kind of like the
joker but much more like an actual clown than the
joker looks like so if you hear people talk about
marvel's joker that's what they're talking about
i'm sure there will be all kinds of questions
about this when the series happens for people who
never read the comic book and are familiar with
the character like wait a minute are they allowed
to do the joker i've already talked about all the
kingpin cameo scene news there's been reports that
he's going to show up a little bit in some of the
later episodes but not be a really huge character
and i know there's been rumors about them changing
the look of the character like making him
fatter to look more like comic book kingpin
i don't know anything about that those are just
rumors but there's this whole thread about the
idea of kevin feige slowly reintroducing the
marvel daredevil netflix characters through some
of these other series before they eventually
do some big time daredevil stuff in the mcu
like a little bit of kingpin during the hawkeye
series teasing him then matt murdock daredevil and
kingpin and some of the other daredevil characters
inside the echo spin-off series episodes
and then maybe a little bit more daredevil during
the she-hulk series there was a report about
daredevil also showing up during she-hulk because
they're both lawyers but i'm not expecting them to
show kingpin in any of these trailers it feels
like if he were going to show up on the series
they would hide that till the actual episode
happens just so it's a much bigger wtf reveal
like holy crap they're actually doing the thing
all this footage of them going around central
park larping and doing this play-acting fighting
is probably part of a stakeout that they're on
if you notice here it also looks like one of
them is wearing a ronin halloween costume and
then there's a new scene with hayley steinfeld's
kate bishop talking to lucky the pizza dog he's
off of frame for some reason there isn't a whole
lot of lucky the pizza dog in this trailer footage
but they're in the apartment and there's actually
a really big deep cut avengers easter egg in
the background on this poster here so the movie
poster is not a poster for a movie in real life
it's a poster for a fake movie inside the mcu but
that references a big comic book avengers event
creature from the black galaxy is a reference to
creature from the black lagoon in actual movie
the black galaxy is this really dangerous
galaxy inside the marvel 616 universe
is the place where ego the living planet came
from but moira brandon was an actress inside the
616 universe who moved from hollywood to chicago
in the estate where she moved to was eventually
bought by the west coast avengers and transformed
into their version of the avengers compound
the other deep cut here is that luke ballard
the other actor that's named on this poster
is actually a person in real life he's part
of the marvel studios visual design team
people do that in movies and television shows
all the time like if you need a giant list of
names or you need names in the background of
a big scene sometimes they'll be comic book
easter eggs sometimes they'll be the names of the
crew members that actually worked on the series
and then they just ended the same joke of
the scene about the trick arrows like wait
a minute trick arrows trick arrows are just
a big part of matt fraction's sense of humor
during his hawkeye run he winds up using a bunch
of the funnier hawkeye trick arrows and during the
scenes where he did use them he called them out in
really funny ways he has used some of them in the
avengers movies but they didn't really focus too
much on them just because usually the action was
on something bigger in whatever scene hawkeye
was in i got so many questions about the loki
arrow on my last hawkeye video too the loki arrow
is just from that first avengers movie that's what
it's a reference to it's just a reference
to the delayed response arrow like delayed
explosion like loki caught it thinking that he'd
one-up hawkeye but then it blew up in his face
but like they say the first two episodes are
dropping november 24th we'll get a couple more
trailers before that happens and obviously
the episodes will overlap with spiderman no
way home so that should be a lot of really cool
stuff happening in the next couple of months
what i'll probably wind up doing is just doing
separate videos for episode one and episode two
and posting both of those on that wednesday
premiere if you spotted any other big easter
eggs during this that i didn't talk about during
the video just write them below in the comments
i've got a couple of the big trailer videos that
i'm working on so i'll try to post those as soon
as possible there was also a brand new what if
season 2 promo that marvel just released so i'll
do a video for that with some cool easter eggs
and then revealing what they're doing with some
of the season two episodes will you wait for
everything everyone click here for that brand
new spider-man no way home preview of all the
sinister six films with a confirmed roster now
and click here to learn about that
new hulk movie that marvel is making
thank you so much for watching everyone stay
safe and i'll see you guys in the next one!